bonjour à toutes et à tous mesdames et
messieurs de toujours du présentes ont
participé à l'événement de lancement du
projet et or du rhin
pour rappel ce projet interreg innovant
mobilise 29 partenaires vise à faire la
promotion du bilinguisme et encourager
l'insertion professionnelle
transfrontalière sur le marché de
l'emploi puis national du rhin supérieur
le webinaire d'aujourd'hui a pour objet
le lancement de la première version qui
sera utilisable du français comme langue
cadres vers l'allemand en tant que
langue cible jeux éducatifs à venir
début 2000 21 sera lancée la seconde
version utilisable de l'allemand comme
langue gare vers le français en tant que
langue site
l'outil sera dès lors entièrement
réversible le président du monde elle
est partante elle nous pouvons
malheureux famine d'adressé salutations
il a représenté laisse donc la parole à
l'essai daniel adrian vers de lozère ont
cédé par total donc de la deuxième
commission appartenant du haut rhin
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à tout le
monde tout le monde l'entend bien
mesdames et messieurs je me permet tout
d'abord de vous saluer toutes celles et
ceux qui sont là aujourd'hui présents
pour notre événement est saluée madame
la rectrice madame elisabeth laporte est
saluée aussi un madame à la veggie
rousse president in venture ou alors son
représentant monsieur dans ce chu lai
monsieur le secrétaire général de la
régie au basilic insiste manuel frise
etc et que j'ai aperçu de tout à l'heure
et aussi et surtout ma collègue pascale
schmidiger qui prendra la suite tout à
l'heure où les explications de ce bel
événement d'aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs bien sûr vous toutes et tous
en bout titres grades et qualités c'est
aussi un plaisir que j'ai aujourd'hui à
vous accueillir où nos deux noms
le président du conseil départemental et
me dit ça a été dit tout à l'heure il ne
peut pas être là pour le lancement de
l'autre application web and craft et 1
tout d'abord merci de participer à notre
événement nous sommes 49 personnes donc
ce n'est pas rien c'est une belle la
visioconférence une des plus grandes les
dit tout à l'heure auxquelles nous
participons et à mesdames et messieurs
même si la forme change un tout petit
peu le fond de notre sujet il leur reste
le même et nous sommes nous sommes
vraiment contents c'est un moment de
joie de pouvoir aujourd'hui lancé lancé
cette aventure puisque l ael à cenon et
lancer cette application cette
application à laquelle nous travaillons
depuis à deux ans je me souviens bien
quand nous l'avions un lancer et
expliqué c'était à une des réunions de
la conférence du rhin supérieur c'était
à bâle exactement où nous avions
expliqué tout ça est lancée laventure et
aujourd'hui grâce aux services du
département et à tous ceux qui nous
entourent à a aussi un les services
académiques
nous arrivons aujourd'hui à concrétiser
ce set cette action et ce jeu alors
pourquoi cette action et nous le savons
toutes et tous le bilinguisme c'est
vraiment un grand sujet de préoccupation
pour nous tous
peu importe le pays d'ailleurs les bills
à 10 mhz et je regarde là et je fais un
petit coucou à nos amis allemands et
suisses bilinguisme c'est bien français
allemands mais c'est aussi allemands
français donc ça va dans les deux sens
et c'est en cela que nous avons d'où
notre grand de responsabilité et 7 et
est comment dire
cette responsabilité lourde dans les
temps je pèse mes mots lourde dans les
temps qui courent puisque nous le savons
tous
nous avons de plus en plus de
difficultés
à trouver des locuteurs de la langue du
voisin juste celui du voisin celui de
l'autre côté de de lure à mr à dessus ne
l'est plus du tout une frontière mais le
fait de ne pas connaître la langue du
voisin
ça aussi c'est une frontière une autre
frontière une frontière dans nos
relations
une frontière par rapport au travail qui
pourrait se faire de mieux en mieux
aussi
mais aussi par rapport à tous nos jeunes
qui pourraient de trouver du travail
dans les autres pays
donc voilà l'importance de la langue
c'est important selon nous la
connaissons toutes et tous est
aujourd'hui vraiment encore une fois je
me répète mais j'en suis conscient c'est
avec vous toutes et tous que nous
partageons cette joie et ce plaisir de
lancer aujourd'hui cette aventure merci
beaucoup monsieur avignon donc dans un
second temps d'inviter de servion madame
pascale schmidiger le maire de saint
louis concert départementale à hauteur
de la ville comme sont action relations
internationales et promotion du
bilinguisme à me dire un petit peu plus
sur le projet et ses principaux
objectifs
je lui cède la parole merci beaucoup mal
à la cheville
bonjour à vous tous et merci à chahr
daniel mais cela drian pour ton
introduction voilà c'est le plaisir et
l'honneur effectivement de vous
présenter les grandes lignes de ce jeu
notre projet or du rhin qui a pour objet
de développer une application mobile
vous le savez tous éducative
un serious game un jeu sérieux attrayant
qui soit capable de changer le regard
que portent les ados sur l'allemagne la
suisse et les inciter à pratiquer la
langue de nos voisins alors avec cette
application nous avons souhaité
développer un outil numérique utilisable
en classe sous la supervision de
l'enseignant ou hors du temps scolaire
pour permettre d'accompagner à travers
des exercices oraux l'acquisition de
quelques 400 mhz au quotidien de la
langue cible donc dans un
le premier temps l'allemand même si le
français pour les allemands l'année
prochaine correspondant à une capacité
seuil qui s'oriente vers le niveau à 1
alors pour cela le jeu éducatif que nous
avons développée est doté d'un logiciel
de reconnaissance vocale
les joueurs peuvent débloquer des
étoiles et in fine et des niveaux par la
voix en prononçant correctement des
réponses à des situations de
communication élémentaire la tolérance
initial élevé du logiciel décroît au fur
et à mesure de la progression
afin d'accompagner les utilisateurs vers
une amélioration de leur précision
phonétique par cette application les
jeunes feront aussi du tourisme le
parcours de jeux virtuels s'ils ont une
carte qui permet de découvrir 55 hull
lieux marquants de la région du rien du
rhin supérieur de balle à germersheim à
côté de ces décors dessinés par un
illustrateur des infobulles interactive
contenant des textes faciles à
comprendre apporte des éclairages
historiques et interculturel aux élèves
alors concernant le nom lennon or du
rhin ou rheingold étant déjà déposé nous
avons choisi avec kraft avec kraft et la
contraction des mots français et
allemands aventure et super kraft super
pouvoirs ce nom avait justement été
choisi pour souligner la dimension
trinationale france suisse et allemagne
bien sûr et la convergence linguistiques
au sein du bassin de vie du rhin
supérieur
alors pourquoi aventure le parcours
virtuel des élèves le long du rhin doit
être perçue comme une aventure
c'est aussi une invitation à les vivre
une aventure bien réelle sur les lieux
mentionnés dans l'application et au delà
du rhin ou des frontières alors les
finalistes du jeu se verront si délivrer
un badge au numérique qui ouvrira droit
à la réalisation d'une journée de
découverte en entreprise ou en alsace tu
ou dans le pays de bade
celle ci sera bien sûr gratuite est pris
en charge par les partenaires éducatifs
alors pourquoi superpouvoirs super kraft
maîtriser la langue et les codes
interculturel du voisin constitue
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous le
savons un atout sur le marché de
l'emploi
ce sera plus simple pour nos jeunes de
trouver un travail
call car ils pourront ils pourront
trouver à 360° sur un travail sur tout
le bassin rhénan et par delà les
frontières
donc je remercie bien entendu l'ensemble
des partenaires qui se sont associés à
la construction de ceux de cet outil
mais aussi qu'il nous permette
effectivement d'aller au delà du jeu
puisqu'il nous l'accueillerons
effectivement dans leur entreprise
ah vous le savez le nombre de
travailleurs frontaliers est très élevé
dans nos régions et le départ à la
retraite d'une large partie de ces
fontes année d'ici une quinzaine
d'années nécessite un renouvellement
efficace et rapide de cette main
d'oeuvre frontalière les opportunités en
suisse du nord ouest notamment en
allemagne du sud est également et en
alsace sont plus nombreuses nous le
savons que dans les autres régions de
nos états nationaux respectifs
quand quelqu'un parle la langue
régionale d'alsace la langue du voisin
on peut donc à cet égard parler d'un
véritable super pouvoirs voici en
quelques mots l'idée du projet de
l'application je pense que nous pouvons
tous en être fier et je re je remercie à
nouveau l'ensemble des partis des
partenaires qui se sont associés à cet
appel mais aussi tous les élèves toutes
les équipes d'enseignants pédagogique
pour leur collaboration étroite dans la
construction de cette application
voilà donc je souhaite de passer la
parole bien sûr aux autres partenaires
du projet et nous allons vous présenter
et aussi une démonstration de cette
application
merci beaucoup mais le chili guerre vous
avez vous évoqué les partenaires
intéressants lesquels le projet n'aurait
pas pu voir le jour nous allons donc
donner la parole aux représentants des
principaux partenaires intérêt légal
donc aux financeurs de ce projet aux
côtés du département ils présenteront
leurs motivations à s'associer au
département du haut-rhin et détailleront
la nature de leur contribution de roger
donc pour mener à bien ce projet
éducatif transfontalier axée autour de
la pratique orale de la langue régionale
d'alsace ainsi la langue du voisin
l'allemand le français selon la
perspective il était crucial vient
dossier le plus de pédagogue enseignant
et donc de méthode également différente
et d'élèves possible l'application comme
l'a ratée match hier
en effet en effet vocation à diffuser
largement et à trouver sa place dans un
maximum de salles de places de part et
d'autre du rhin à cet égard le soutien
les expertises des autorités scolaires
françaises allemandes et suisses étaient
une perf est immoral cette méthode de co
construction qui latéral harmonieuse
avec de développer des projets
l'application avec arte à partir
d'activités distant ciel collectif lundi
google réunissant des classes pilotes
cela fut possible en dépit des
restrictions sanitaires et même
déconfinement dont 100 m de l'époque la
créativité et l'ingéniosité des équipes
et les enseignants partenaires du projet
notre projet n'aurait pas pu voir le
jour sans le soutien sans faille du
rectorat à rebours à travers notamment
de la délégation académique pour les
relations internationales et les langues
du canton ainsi j'expire nos équipes
techniques de très loin de
reconnaissance au rectorat les travaux
nous avons la chance et la thaïlande
satisfaction d'accueillir madame la
rectrice et chancelier des universités
et isabelle d'abord à qui je sais la
parole mais est-ce que vous pouvez la
porte je vous celle là j'ai pris la
parole
je voulais je suis désolé je vous ai
interrompu et j'ai pris la parole est ce
que tout le monde l'entend oui donc
apparemment tout le monde l'entend je
vous salue tous tout particulièrement
monsieur adrian madame schmidiger et nos
amis allemands et suisses du rhin
supérieur
bonjour à tout le monde alors cette
cette visioconférence fait écho à la
commission quadripartite que nous avons
réuni hier soir
vous savez cette fameuse commission qui
associe les trois grandes collectivités
de l'académie de strasbourg c'est à dire
la région le département et l'éducation
nationale et qui est donc en charge que
tout va bien évidemment ghislain glisse
mme dans le sillage de toute cette
culture et cette identité territoriale
également dans le sillage du traité de
d'aix la chapelle qui nous imposent de
promouvoir la maîtrise de la langue du
voisin
dans cet espace transfrontalier et dans
l'espace plus large franco allemand donc
je me réjouis et je tiens vraiment à
remercier les collectivités les deux
départements pour cette initiative qui
va permettre de d'assurer une transition
nécessaire pour que l'allemand passe de
la langue scolaire et d'une langue
d'enseignement à une langue réellement
de communication c'est à dire que la
maîtrise d'une langue nous le savons
dépasse largement le cadre exclusivement
scolaire il faut dépasser ses frontières
scolaire extrascolaires et cette
application permettra de s'amuser avec
l'allemand
avoue kraft s'est aussi mêlé le plaisir
à l'apprentissage et c'est permettre un
apprentissage en quelque sorte sans
effort cela va contribuer là
l'exposition à la langue et qui va
permettre donc de conduire à des
automatismes linguistique
donc je trouve que c'est vraiment une
initiative formidable et bien évidemment
je la soutiens à 200% et tous mes
services et les enseignants d'allemand
jeu j'en suis sûr soutiennent également
cette application
donc merci à tous ceux qui ont travaillé
qu'ils ont élaborés merci également à
tous nos voisins allemands qui ont su
qu'ils ont contribué également à cet
outil est bien évidemment aux
enseignants et aux élèves des
établissements concernés qui ont
expérimenté cette application
voilà ce que je voulais dire aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup madame la rectrice
donc je vais maintenant passer la parole
à l'autre partenaire éducatif essentiel
de ce projet un qui est le raidillon de
césium de freiburg le régime du
président bédié de freiburg été un des
premiers partenaires à s'engager à sept
associés au projet et qui a la science
du système français comporte en son sein
du coup et les administrations vous
pouvez dire préfectoral et les équipes
contredire électorales notamment les
équipes de la heart and soul en 2011 qui
ont très fortement contribué au succès
de cette première version
nous avons donc le très grand plaisir
d'accueillir monsieur qui vous
représente devant les maires de
schaeffer la région ce pays qui depuis
lui cet outil la parole
en quelques minutes il ya finbank la
présidente
adrien aux preuves et l'inde ni dégâts
l'ibama l'ol frisé que madame la
rectrice il tafforeau chez fat rythme
dit hamid karzaï ont été rabotées
la cour d'assises par effectif du match
car j'ai déjà conduit une attaque à la
grenade faisait faute à pas de chance
ristic mais il est en stand by amazon
dit il trop premier est destiné à être
un outil digne et de conception des
sociétés à passer ce meeting d'un
district of a party for children du
ladakh la sarthe
non une honte c'est une information de
france prenant toutes sont familiaux par
une série d'exposés du mahdi fera règle
sera chaud lapin longueuil tous masqués
plus tard spyker a dit me jean paul
beeston le moment cela indique jules à
110 francs sur deux je les ai pas marre
mediamath aux éditions maine s'ignorent
selon la feuille de match par semaine et
235 banque est vieux un grand merci à
vous monsieur jules eux nous avons
aujourd'hui également le plaisir
d'accueillir des représentants de nos
partenaires suisses 1 les cantons de
bâle-ville bâle-campagne argovie soleure
et jura ainsi que de la confédération
helvétique commente et un soutien
technique très conséquent de même que un
apport d'importants cofinançant ces
autorités politiques et scolaire suisse
ont été pleinement associés au projet
par le biais de la review baghdatis et
du pédagogue juste l um de base aux
stats référent intercantonaux représenté
par le docteur manuel frisé coeur et un
angle un brick d'accord global
cette implication très forte des partis
suisses nous rappelle qu'en dépit du
fait que la suisse ne soit pas pays
membres de l'union elle d'excellentes
relations transnationales qui existe au
sein de la région trinationale du rhin
supérieur en lâchant transnationales
durablement consolidé par le programme
interreg un supérieur
il permet des contributions ces fuites
les concernant et dont la parole à
monsieur au dr politique une pile donc
50 mn inside m6 arte femme starting
troops and mr jean claude chef ce furent
de récompenser les indices ont tout en
contenant une compétition juste et les
deux récompenses il ya six ans
esthétique en vie
photo martin school in peace a chance a
retenu un contexte et surtout parce
qu'ils contrôlent et culturels
outre offres comprennent son style rock
so vie au petit format trier les données
secrètes de mobilité douce il trentino
la compagnie film fortis cohn bendit à
l'espace et au temps des projecteurs
en fait le fruit d'un project on te
rends randgold l'un des fils support
kraft l'enquêté un très grand merci à
vous monsieur wiesel donc nous allons
céder la parole à monsieur à lyon va
devoir nous nous quitter monsieur ligne
en vous avez la parole est ensuite nous
donnons la parole à madame l'image merci
mesdames et messieurs un petit mot avant
de vous quitter je suis malheureusement
de l'obligation de vous quitter je suis
aussi maire d'une commune émis
d'obligations à bons appels et les
obligations prises avant le lancement de
cette grande aventure d'aujourd'hui et
tout à l'heure je le je n'ai pas dit où
les remerciements que j'avais à faire et
que je voulais faire parce que je
voulais d'abord que ma collègue et ami
par pascale schmidiger explique vraiment
le tenant et les aboutissants et elle
l'a très bien fait merci à vous aussi
madame la rectrice nous avons été
sensibles à votre soutien et a surtout à
cette promotion de la langue allemand
que vous nous avez expliqué alors
permettez-moi rapidement quand même
d'énumérer quelques partenaires
importants dans nos beaux merci mots qui
ont permis la réalisation de ce projet
parce qu'il ya aussi des moyens
financiers derrière ce projet des moyens
humains des moyens financiers et tout
d'abord les fonds européens intérêt que
ça a été soulignée tout à leurs
partenaires allemands et suisses vous
êtes intervenu merci monsieur jules et
merci monsieur prise et qu'elle est
super vos interventions au rapport a
vraiment la prise de conscience de ce
que nous avons à travailler ensemble
j'apprécie vraiment de tout coeur à ce
que ce que vous venez de nous expliquer
l'éducation nationale madame la rectrice
vous avez là une place très importante
mais vous venez de le dire il n'y a pas
que l'enseignement de l'allemand il faut
le continuer et si nous le conte
tillion balloon n'y arriveront pas moi
personnellement je défends depuis
longtemps
premièrement nous avons à travailler
avec nos amis sans bonnet blanc la lah
nom de nos arbitres du sceau de paris à
voilà c'est des choses très simples donc
merci à l'éducation nationale des
partenaires à la chambre de commerce au
réseau canopée qui certes est autour de
l'éducation nationale mais c'est
important
le reggae roots presidio main fribourg
plus spécialement monsieur jules est
encore une fois est bien sûr notre
prestataire almedia aura vraiment ce
travail de grande qualité
nous avons eu la chance d'autres jours
d'avoir une présentation c'est vraiment
de la qualité
merci à tous les 29 partenaires du
projet et à tous les élèves ils ont été
nombreux les et un merci monsieur l'aide
avoir évoqué les partenaires aussi un
enfant aux jeunes de ceux de ce projet
et nous connaissons particulièrement le
quang inazuma de barils avec lequel
personnellement là où je travaille nous
avons un partenariat et tous ces jeunes
nous ont aidés à développer ce projet
alors gros vente vraiment grand succès à
toutes les aventures
mesdames et messieurs merci pour votre
présence et surtout votre application et
malheureusement je vous quitter je vous
dis à une prochaine voilà et surtout
belle aventure avec raph vie riche petit
fils craft of mr de mer à schaffhouse me
donald tusk et finale merci filmant le
monsieur à lyon nous allons maintenant
laisser la parole à madame marie paule
lehmann donc vice présidente du conseil
départemental du bas-rhin et vers le
chalonnais nous fait l'honneur de sa
présence et qui représente monsieur avec
berry madame lehmann vous avez
maintenant c'est un tout petit temps de
parole que je vais utiliser simplement à
défaut merci à tous les partenaires et
spécialement à nos collègues haut
rhinois qui ont porté avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme et de
d'investissement ce projet pascal adrien
cela brillant voilà merci je connais un
petit peu moins les autres personnes
puisque normalement cmc meyer les
chargés de ces dossiers on conseil
départemental du bas-rhin
donc je m'arrêterai là je suis très
heureuse cependant d'avoir vu qu'un
collège de mon canton et décodeurs times
a participé à haïti classes pilotes donc
je les en remercie sincèrement et
j'espère que ce projet va être porté sur
l'intégralité de notre de notre bassin
de vie sera supérieure et d'après ce que
j'ai compris
on commence en alsace voilà merci à tous
et je reste avec vous pour découvrir le
jeu doit nous apprendre un progression
d'allemand et je pense que j'en ai un
petit peu besoin merci beaucoup
un immense merci à vous madame lehmann
le partenaires suivants a déjà été
évoqué donc par le siad liant epalinges
miel s'agit du réseau canopée et est un
partenaire essentiel un très fort
soutien en matière de montage et de
gestion de projet ainsi que l'ingénierie
pédagogique partenaire fort de sa très
riche expérience de développement de
ressources numériques éducatives à
destination entre autres des collégiens
une structure déjà porteuse par le passé
aux est bien connu à chaque coup là à
destination des élèves
imer donc toucher plaisir d'accueillir
pour la direction territoriale le réseau
canopée camp-est monsieur yves schneider
no mercy sa présence
vous avez la parole de schneider merci
je voudrais premier lieu effectivement
vous remercier monsieur ancely frei pour
vos paroles très très aimable
remerciements aussi à l'ensemble des
vingt-sept partenaires pour les
relations je dirais de confiance est
très productive que nous avons pu avoir
durant ce durant ce projet
particulièrement bien sûr l'académie de
strasbourg au conseil départemental du
bas-rhin mais et surtout en particulier
au conseil départemental du haut rhin
pour le pilotage dire est très dynamique
et très positif de ce beau projet de cet
ambitieux projet les modalités de
travail que je viens de décrire ont été
à l'image du projet c'est-à-dire
innovante créative participative est ce
qui ressort des multiples rencontres qui
ont ponctué ce projet celle dynamisme le
volontarisme je crois qu'il faut le
souligner et de l'ensemble des
partenaires pour concrétiser un objet
aujourd'hui ce n'est qu'une étape mais
c'est une étape importante à la hauteur
du défi
c'est à dire permettre au jeune public
de s'initier aux lentes les cultures du
rhin supérieur de venir pour ces jeunes
des acteurs au plan social éducatif
culturel professionnel aussi et ce à
l'échelle de l'ensemble du territoire
dont on mesure bien le potentiel que cet
outil recel et toute la richesse qui
sera progressivement révélés quelques
éléments simplement rapide sur les
points d'appui
je dirais 2
si on était des supports au
développement dans le champ notamment
technologiques mais aussi au plan
culturel et sociétal pour le
développement de ce set applicateur de
cette application ses points d'appui
sont évidemment des points d'appui en
premier lieu qui repose sur la culture
numérique sur le code numérique
c'est un élément tout à fait essentiel
parce que il s'agit là aujourd'hui
véritablement d'un nouveau paradigme
sociétal un fait social la diffusion de
la culture numérique traversent la
société id apportait d'utiliser je
dirais ce code pour barrer bien diffuser
les contenus de notre application et
particulièrement les usages autour de
l'apprentissage des langues de
l'initiation culture du rhin supérieur
le deuxième élément sur lequel je
voudrais simplement dire deux mots c'est
la question finalement des échelles et
c'est vrai que le numérique est aussi un
moyen de dépasser les échelles
territoriales de de s'exprimer à
l'échelle
alors ici du rhin supérieur mais aussi
d'être ouvert au vaste monde
d'une certaine manière et dans le
multiculturalisme et dans l' approche
multiculturelle
ces outils numériques aucune importance
tout à fait essentiel et stratégique ils
ont été un point d'appui encore dans ce
domaine extrêmement important
enfin la dimension participative
contributive de ces outils sont cette
dimension est un élément aussi tout à
fait important à travers le potentiel ce
potentiel créatif que recèle
l'application avec kraft à travers sa
capacité aussi à générer des échanges et
je crois que c'est un point important à
interagir à permettre une interaction
notamment sur les contenus un élément
également c'est bien sûr la la
gamification de la société qui
aujourd'hui est un élément qu'on peut
particulièrement noté sur laquelle
repose aussi ce projet et je rappelle
que
je en pédagogie est un support tout à
fait intéressant notamment dans le
développement des approches actionnelle
pour pour apprendre donc on a là je
crois des points d'appui qui ont été
véritablement extrêmement solide et qui
ont permet permis pardon de développer
cette application en définitive et pour
conclure je dirais que c'est une
expérience une réalisation qui rentrent
aujourd'hui dans une phase de lancement
et de diffusion mais cette phase de
lancement et de diffusion est en quelque
sorte un second commencement et on a
parlé beaucoup de enfin je j'ai parlé
beaucoup de numérique mais je crois que
il ya aussi l'enjeu de l'accompagnement
donc second commencement à suivre a
accompagné de près afin de communiquer
de faire connaître de favoriser aussi
les usages en contexte scolaire mais
également dans l'éducation plus
largement dans l'éducation informelle et
je voudrais le dire aujourd'hui que
réseau canopée sera évidemment également
au rendez vous de ce nouveau défi qui
commence
afin de faciliter le développement de ce
jeu sérieux au plus grand bénéfice des
publics des apprenants et de leur
ouverture linguistique et culturelle au
haut rhin supérieur
un très grand merci à vous monsieur
schneider et aux ateliers canopée
lousien et strasbourgeois qui ont mal
aux et du temps de travail et qui se
révélaient des atouts inestimables de
par leur flexibilité disponibilité
qualité en poussière avant gardiste dans
les méthodes
merci un grand merci je sais maintenant
la parole au directeur transfrontalier
de la chambre de commerce et industrie
alsace gros métropole qui est toujours
indispensable créateurs de contenus dans
les relations écoles entreprises les
puissants auprès des entreprises et des
salons professionnels du rhin supérieur
la chambre de commerce qui valorise
également du temps de travail au titre
du volet emploi et insertion
professionnelle transfrontalière de ce
projet a déjà été évoqué par messieurs
adrian et et management year je laisse
la parole à monsieur franck reuter merci
beaucoup
bonjour monsieur on se dit bonjour aux
autres partenaires du projet je vais pas
les citer nommément mais je les salue de
manière collective tout d'abord je tiens
à excuser l'absence de leur président
jean luc heimburger qui aurait aimé être
là mais qui malheureusement dans ces
temps un peu compliqué pour le commerce
et la restauration elle est occupée par
des choses très très urgente vous le
comprendrez p l'engagement de la cci
dans le développement du bilinguisme et
de l'apprentissage transfrontalier que
je souhaite aller à cette manifestation
n'est plus à prouver que ce soit par des
actions comme goethe chaque match
houleux avec nos partenaires des
chambres de commerce allemande
l'organisation des nuits de
l'orientation ou tout un volet sur le
transfrontalier était prévu les années
précédentes
ou alors l'accompagnement de jeunes
français sur les salons emploi formation
côté allemand pour la faire découvrir de
nouveaux métiers sont détournés des
actions que nous menons depuis quelques
années déjà
le projet amène kraft est une nouveauté
une nouvelle façon d'apprendre la langue
du voisin et elle favorisa favorisera
cet apprentissage de manière ludique et
novatrice
je tiens aussi à souligner l'importance
de la langue allemande n'est donc en
général dans le développement des
entreprises à l'international
une anecdote lors d'un récent sondage
pascoli de que nous avons effectuée
auprès de 1600 entreprises 60 % des
entreprises qui n'étaient pas sur le
marché de l'international souhaite se
développer à l'international
ce qui sous-entend également le
recrutement de nouvelles compétences et
l'importance de ces langues dans cette
activité
la cci comme la démission cela ne fait
pas le répéter soutiendra le projet hors
notamment par la mise à disposition le
cofinancement du spécialiste l'expert de
l'apprentissage transfrontalier mais en
tant que membre d'attac force et
l'animation du comité technique c'est on
participe pas à un différend actions et
surtout choses importantes
en guise de conclusion la cci mobilisera
toutes les entreprises et communiquera
auprès des tout toutes ces entreprises
pour
valoriser avec kraft et faire connaître
kraft pour favoriser l'apprentissage
merci bonjour merci beaucoup monsieur
reuter et pour finir du coup nous allons
laisser la parole aux partenaires
associés aux deux autres partenaires
projet l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse s'ils le souhaitent et
l'eurodistrict al mourr aux normes et je
vous demandais de dette assez bref car
nous spectateurs et spectatrices
d'impatience à souhait et se réjouissent
de pouvoir la démonstration maintenant
donc si vous souhaitez prendre la parole
je vous prie de bien vouloir lever la
main électronique
merci d'avancé oui monsieur froehly cher
donc présidente de l'association eltern
alsace vous avez la parole
bonjour tout est juste saluer tous les
participants dont de nombreux ont
participé à notre assemblée générale la
semaine dernière où on a parlé du projet
avec kraft qui voulait juste faire un
petit clin d'oeil que j'ai déjà sera une
petite répétition pour pour certains qui
étaient avec nous la semaine dernière un
petit clin d'oeil pour saluer maxime
fraichard qui je crois c'est une un
stage dans l'entreprise qui a développé
avec kraft est le clin d'oeil c'est que
maxime freixa est un jeune homme dont
les parents ne parle absolument pas le
l'allemand ni la langue nationale et qui
a suivi un cursus bilingue qui a fait
partie de la première cohorte des
stagiaires qui sont allés faire leur
stage en allemagne dans le cadre du
projet euros stage 2020 nous sommes
partenaires avec un certain nombre
d'entre vous et des financements
européens également et ce jeune homme a
fait 1 je crois un stage dans
l'entreprise qui a développé le
l'application donc gens que je vois là
un symbole très positif de des
perspectives que peut donner
l'enseignement bilingue et je trouve que
c'est une
c'est un clin d'oeil tout à fait
sympathique voilà c'était juste une
petite remarque liminaire
merci beaucoup monsieur folichon donc il
ya pas deux dernières prises de paroles
très très rapide
nous allons
suivre avec le nerf de la guerre si je
puis dire at-elle au nerf de la guerre
avec le vif du sujet donc le jeu
éducatif à notre hâte à proprement
parler je ne vois pas de prise de parole
donc je vous propose de laisser la
parole aux équipes du dal média
prestataires notamment en toi une vanne
ingénieurs pédagogique chea le méga il
va tout d'abord vous présenter une vidéo
de démonstration du jeu vous montrer un
support explicatifs sur les choix qui
ont présidé à l'apparence et au nom des
personnages
celui ci est également quelques exemples
de ces 55 ans en visitant du jeu et
dessiné par un illustrateur médaillés du
festival hors décès d'angoulême
s'il vous plaît parole à antoine donc
avant de lancer la vidéo effectivement
je voulais confirmer à monsieur froelich
heures effectivement maxime fait un
stage chez nous donc le clin d'oeil elle
était très bien vu et je voulais aussi
remercié les différents interlocuteurs
qui m'ont précédé puisque vous avez déjà
très bien présenté l'application
notamment madame schmidiger vous avez
très bien présenté le serious game donc
je vais pas revenir en détail dessus ma
vente danse et la vidéo sachez juste
qu'effectivement le but du jeu c'est de
les courir le rhin donc d'allier de
lieux en d'un lieu à un autre et de
discuter avec des célébrités locales
donc du rhin supérieur
donc je vais tout de suite lancé la
vidéo donc j'ai partagé l'écran
alors là et vous me direz si vous
entendez bien tout mais normalement ça
devrait être le cas
à vannes kraft est un jeu éducatif
ludique pour l'apprentissage au niveau 1
point 1 de l'allemand ou du français
ce jeu éducatif est destiné aux
adolescents entre 12 et 16 ans le
département du haut-rhin en
collaboration avec une trentaine
d'acteurs du rhin supérieur au sein du
projet lors du rhin rheingold a fait le
constat d'une baisse conséquente du
nombre de travailleurs transfrontaliers
ce jeu éducatif est donc offert en tant
que nouvelle offre de formation
linguistique et interculturel
concrètement comment se déroule le jeu
le joueur circulent dans la région du
rhin supérieur en se rendant d'un lieu à
l'autre et dans chaque lieu il va
pouvoir rencontrer un personnage et
dialoguer avec lui
il va aussi pouvoir découvrir des
informations sur le lieu grâce aux
points culturels mis en interaction avec
lui à l'écran
en chaque lieu le joueur peut interagir
avec un personnage on appelle une
célébrité du rhin supérieur dont le
visuel est inspirée justement d'un
personnage illustre de la région le
dialogue se déroule de la manière
suivante bobigny le personnage pose une
question ou donne une information aux
joueurs à l'oral et le joueur doit tout
simplement appuyé sur le micro visible à
l'écran pour répondre à ce personnage
l'apprentissage d'une nouvelle langue se
fait donc à l'oral dans l'exemple
présenté ici à l'écran le personnage
inspiré d'auguste bartholdi a demandé
aux joueurs mobiles riches où suis-je
le joueur doit appuyé sur le micro et
répondre ford herbaut car il s'agit de
la bonne réponse qui sera validé par le
logiciel de reconnaissance vocale
le joueur dispose de deux types ted des
aides pour comprendre le personnage et
des aides pour lui répondre par l'état
les aides pour lui répondre sont
disponibles sous forme d'icônes et donne
la réponse soit en français donc le
joueur dans la traduire soit en allemand
donc il doit jusque là lire soit il y à
une aide qui donne la réponse
oralement aux joueurs cette aide fait
perdre beaucoup de points mais ainsi
nous nous assurerons que le joueur ne
soit jamais bloquée dans le jeu
d'où les différents dialogues plonge le
joueur dans des situations réalistes à
nos coeurs et voit sa pda
c'est à dire qu'il pourrait vivre en
voyageant à l'étranger mais promesse au
ram et bruxelles
met pas ma specter
certains dialogues tourne autour de
l'emploi des stages en entreprise des
stages de découverte ou professionnel
coûte mort gérer ces gens jugent binda
ita team art bat hervé dit
tout le sel de ce serious game est donc
de donner envie aux joueurs de traverser
la frontière que ce soit pour faire un
stage mais aussi pour découvrir une
culture qui à la fois différentes et
similaires
[Musique]
bien que l'objectif principal de ce
serious games soit apprentissage d'une
nouvelle langue
il a également pour but de montrer aux
joueurs que le rhin supérieur est une
région riche en lieux cultes et célèbre
dans chaque lieu des points culturels
sont présents sous forme d'un faux bull
qui sont affichées à l'écran lorsque le
joueur cliquer sur l'un de ses points
culturels
il lui est affiché à l'écran des
informations sur le lieu en question ça
peut être des anecdotes plutôt ludique
historique géographique etc etc
chaque lieu possède ainsi ses propres
anecdotes afin de donner envie aux
joueurs soient de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir un lieu qu'ils connaissaient
ou non auparavant
enfin en termes de fonctionnalités
d'apprentissage le serious game propose
également des mini jeux ces mini jeux
tournent autour de l'apprentissage d'une
nouvelle langue soit d'un nouveau
vocabulaire soit d'une nouvelle tournure
de phrase
les mini jeux permettent ainsi de
parfaire son niveau de l'an tout en
s'amusant
en variant les situations
d'apprentissage et 11 en sorte que le
joueur puisse rapidement revoir les
différents mots qu'il aura appris durant
sa progression dans le rhin supérieur
[Musique]
comme vous venez de l'entendre les sons
dans les mini-jeux sont présents afin
d'indiquer aux joueurs s'il a répondu de
manière correcte ou non
l'interface des mini-jeux se veut simple
afin de rendre leur utilisation agréable
et intuitive
tous les éléments présentés auparavant
sont disponibles dans le quartier
général du joueur qui d'un point de vue
scénaristique l académie des super héros
on y retrouve dans ce qg un résumé de
l'histoire que le joueur peut consulter
pour voir sa progression et en connaître
un petit peu plus sur l'histoire des
super héros
on y trouve également la salle des
badges chaque badge correspond en fait à
un métier on y retrouve le badge de
bienvenue bien entendu mais également le
badge de métallurgie par exemple où le
battu la propreté ou encore le badge
électricité ainsi que les badges de tous
les autres métiers qui seront présentées
en vidéo dans des capsules qui seront
disponibles en ligne en février 2021 à
partir du quartier général le joueur
apprenant à accès à l'ensemble des mini
jeux qui ont ponctué les dialogues ils
sont classés à la fois par thèmes ou par
type de mini jeux dans le qg
on trouve également les 55 lieu que le
joueur aura découvert tout au long de sa
progression
ces lieux sont répartis entre la france
l'allemagne et la suisse enfin au
quartier général
le joueur a également accès à la salle
des célébrités qui regroupe l'ensemble
des visuels des personnages du jeu soit
plus d'une vingtaine de personnages avec
lesquels le joueur va pouvoir dialoguer
tout au long du jeu avec kraft est donc
à la fois un jeu éducatif puis à
l'apprentissage d'une nouvelle langue
est un jeu ludique grâce au scénario des
super héros du rhin supérieur
comme le temps défile nous allons déjà
passé à ce moment très attendu de du
premier échange tu remercies en bonne
voie cette présentation très complète de
l'outil et nous allons du coup prendre
des questions ont cherché de chair
participants et représentants de la
presse et enseignants ou connaissant
vous poser toutes les questions qui vous
brûle les lèvres sur le jeu avec aux
équipes du prestataire novembre
représentant du temps
hugo reyne par un haut représentant des
partenaires intérêts vous pouvez prendre
la parole en levant la main électronique
ou vous la tribu roues dans l'ordre des
demandes et dans la limite du temps
imparti à cet assaut webinaire
interactif je vous remercie
le temps que les personnes et soit avec
les schistes aux questions qu'elles
voudraient poser nous avons reçu
quelques questions de classe les classes
participant des classes pilotes et des
enseignants de thann qui n'ont pas pu
être présent aujourd'hui pour des
raisons pour fins sanitaires
on se sent tellement possible je les
adresse avant toile et aux élus donc une
comme la question comment s'est fait le
choix des dessins et selon quels
critères encore antoine si tu peux un
petit peu ré expliquer la méthode et le
l'origine de ces des choix les lieux et
les personnages du jeu je remercie
oui alors donc effectivement et déjà il
ya plusieurs pans différent il ya les
personnages qui ont été choisis et les
lieux qui ont été choisis de manière
démocratique c'est à dire que tous les
partenaires du projet pouvait proposer
soit un personnage soit lieu soit
plusieurs personnages et plusieurs lieux
puis il ya eu un vote démocratique parce
qu'on pouvait bien sûr pas tous les
intégrer on a eu plus de 80 propositions
de personnages plus d'une centaine de
propositions de lieux et donc le vote a
permis de faire une hiérarchie des lieux
et des personnages qui allait apparaître
dans le jeu
ensuite concernant le style de dessin
donc là encore une fois le premier à
caton qui avait eu lieu en mars ou avril
nous avait permis de justement de
bifurquer c'est là aussi où les classes
avaient pu participer donc à la
conception de ce serious games c'est à
dire que au départ le jeu devait se
passer dans un univers en fait de
pirates des temps modernes avec un
personnage principal qui naviguent sur
le rhin et on avait proposé donc
certains visuels aux différentes classes
qui avaient pu voter qui avait pu
s'exprimer justement sur ce style de
visuels et sur l'univers et on s'était
rendu compte donc almedia mais aussi les
partenaires que cet univers tu les as
peut-être moins que d'autres univers
notamment les super héros
est-ce que lors de ce même à caton on
leur avait demandé de dessiner voilà les
personnages qui les inspirent en terme
de force de super héros de pouvoir et on
s'était rendu compte que ça ait eu
beaucoup de succès donc c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on nous avions changé d'univers
donc de passer de pire des temps
modernes un univers de super héros que
les jeunes connaissent bien notamment
grâce à tout le film aux films marvel à
l'univers cinématographique de marvel
mais aussi le style visuel des dessins
voilà nous avons changé d'un style un
peu très dessinée à quelque chose de
plus manga comics grâce justement aux
votes des élèves une première question
de madame merkel nucléaire elle classes
ont participé au projet je vais un
responsable
donc il y avait une classe pilote au
collège charles valls de 2 à charleval
chez les enseignants à la levée des cas
et madame et de ses collègues dont le
nom de revient pas je suis degrés une
classe pilote au collège gérard nerval
ville à 9,1 anthony çi 1 une tasse
pilotes 1 deux classes pilotes par an au
collège du corps le trust of time avec
madame woerth mais d'un père la veille
des essais c'est bio et ensuite ses
classes pilotes allemande des
enseignantes pas la pièce madame ben
rhodes a aucun recul à zoom de beinheim
et également la participation de la
suisse à bâle ville celle de madame
martins lane martha marque un nom les
remercions d'allemands tout et tout
tout ce sont des femmes et leur
participation
j'avais une autre question de madame de
monsieur poulin sur l'origine du choix
du titre avaient acheté je vais laisser
la parole à madame schmidiger pour
expliquer du coup le choix et a présidé
à la construction de alors avec kraft 1
c'est la contraction français allemand
de démo aventure et super kraft voilà
donc c'est un mot que je dirais
multiculturelle que nous pouvons
comprendre à la fois en français et en
allemand
c'était en fait pour souligner la
dimension bien sûr trinationale et la
convergence linguistiques au sein du
bassin du rhin supérieur
alors pourquoi aventure parce que le jeu
se présente effectivement sous une forme
d'aventuré en aventure sur l'ensemble
des territoires du bassin rhénan et puis
kraft voit la super pouvoir vous donne
effectivement ses personnages par la
progression dans l'apprentissage des
différents mots voilà donc est ce que
j'ai fait ce que j'ai répondu à la
question
je pense que oui match d'hier en tout
cas si besoin de précision de ce cousin
écrire et n'hésitez pas à prendre la
parole en direct ou à écrire un message
dans le chat donc je une nouvelle
question le jeu peut-il être enrichie de
nouveaux lieux de nouveaux personnages
de défis supplémentaires ou de dialogue
supplémentaire question de monsieur
poulin je laisse la parole entre halal
mais il ya enfin l'institut un petit peu
alors oui j'ai envie de dire d'un point
de vue numérique tout est toujours
possible on peut enrichir le jeu
effectivement alors en l'état actuel
szavay hun qui sort ça a été déjà évoqué
tout à l'heure donc pour apprendre
l'allemand
on va aussi dès maintenant développer la
v2 qui sera pour l'apprentissage du
français donc la réversibilité
mais par la suite on peut tout à fait
imaginer rajouter des quêtes avec les
nouveaux lieux des nouveaux personnages
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
envisageable
il ya une demande de prise de parole du
collège aux équipes pour que les
enseignants aux agressions nous reste à
voir si le jeu oui tout à fait tout à
fait le jeu est disponible sur android
et devrait disponible ses cendres sous
peu ce weel sous ios donc via l'apple
store donc vous pourrez télécharger cet
après-midi et commencer à y jouer
ouais le jeu est disponible alors nous
avons une autre question de lafitte
mayer est ce que vous voulez la poser
directement puisque vous les analyses
dans le sens répond john part je vais la
lire alors précisé que ce jeu n'est pas
seulement à des stations des élèves mais
qui peut aussi servir aux jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi alors oui c'est
plutôt une remarque alors tout à fait
l'objectif étant bien rares stations sur
le marché de l'emploi national du rhin
supérieur
est-ce qui peut servir jeunes de
nombreux emplois qui aimerait développer
leur vocabulaire pour travailler en
allemagne
donc on peut aller découvrir
effectivement une certains termes
spécialisés
on l'a vu dans la chimie et la
métallurgie et des autres effectivement
secteur professionnel nous donnons la
parole aux chaînes intervenants à
monsieur à monsieur devoir en histoire
de la narine que je dois enlever la
parole bonjour à toutes et à tous je
suis donc du milieu droit je suis
responsable de l'action régionale
transfrontalière mpg anglophone au
rectorat de l'académie strasbourg à
jouer à tout d'abord remercié évidemment
celles et ceux qui étaient à
l'initiative de ce jeu mais également
les équipes qui ont travaillé derrière
les équipes techniques et surtout aussi
évidemment les enseignants qui ont été
ou expérimenter ce jeu et notre chargé
de mission à bernadets de galles qui
s'est beaucoup investi pour aboutir pour
aider aboutir à ce résultat
jeudi une petite juste une petite
remarque baissé ça doit être une erreur
de frappe
je pense qu'il s'agit de louise weiss
n'ont pas de louise vis dedans le dans
les personnages que c'est une petite
correction qui seraient apportées plus
généralement la proche de la découverte
de l'espace du rhin supérieur par ces
lieux importants alors qu'ils soient
culturels ou sportifs autres me semble
très intéressante et attractif pour les
jeunes c'est pourquoi nous avons aussi
depuis un certain temps nous étions a
investit aussi dans passe partout qui
est un peu le même objectif et nous
avons finalisé nous venons de finaliser
une carte interactive avec géo reina
pour les classes afin qu'elles puissent
découvrir les musées et les lieux
culturels dans l'espace du rhin
supérieur
simplement un moment donné on
réfléchisse à une articulation entre ces
différents outils afin que qu'elle
puisse que ces outils puissent profiter
au mieux aux élèves individuellement
mais aussi aux classes dont
de manière collective une question
technique par rapport à la place de
l'oral monsieur graal vous avez présenté
les mini jeux je pense que vous visez le
jeu vise un niveau horaire ou l'oral est
effectivement est certainement le pont
des rangs cependant je n'ai pas
l'impression que quand par exemple quand
il place des mots ils ne peuvent que les
lire il ne les entendent pas c'est bien
sa vie tout à fait donc effectivement en
fait les munitions les a rajouté un peu
comme un bonus le coeur du jeu c'est
vraiment le dialogue il ça se passe à
l'oral avec le lait les différents
personnages
les mini-jeux pour l'instant sont en
termes de bonus pour voilà changer un
petit peu de style apprentissage mais
c'est envisagé pour la v2 le faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent les entendre oui
c'est les différents mort au lieu de les
lire effectivement oui non parce que par
définition ils ne savent pas les lire et
si l'elysée voulait vivre à la française
et donc ça fait beaucoup de questions et
je vous remercie et donc qu'on a une
note d'observations et de la correction
va apporter une manne avis donc l'on
sait encore rendre vains comme demandant
laisser la parole et merci je vous en
prie on a cité précédemment semaine du
côté 1 ou collège charles walch de thann
donc on avait une autre question d'art
élèves du collège charles va justement
mme été transmise par l'enseignante
l'application sera payante 1 et là je
rassure nous les jeunes nous écouter les
moins jeunes aux participants
l'application aidés financés par le
département du haut-rhin et ses
partenaires l'intérieur sera absolument
gratuite sera téléchargeable librement
depuis les app stores et enfin le store
de google le store ios à l'app store 'n'
voilà donc je vais maintenant laisser la
parole à monsieur poulin qui voulaient
exprimer
zuma d'amour c'est pas monsieur poulin
c'est madame c'est pas grave
donc je travaille au rectorat de
strasbourg en tant que chargé édition
les ressources pédagogiques et donc
j'aurais eu grand plaisir à indexer
cette nouvelle ressource parmi celles
qui sont proposées aux enseignants et
aux parents à ce que je pense que c'est
ouvert aussi et que ça intéressera
nombre de familles pour pouvoir jouer
jouer ensemble j'aurais j'aurai une
question concernant
bonjour je re je rebondis aussi sur la
notion de doral je pense que l'oralité
et le fait de pouvoir entendre et harley
est essentiel puisque on peut pas se
baser uniquement sur l'écrit et sur la
lecture
moi j'aurai une question concernant
l'interaction entre les différents
joueurs
est ce que c'est possible est ce que
c'est possible de jouer à plusieurs sur
sur sur l'application et d'entrer en
communication
je précise que je ne suis pas dans la
liste des participants c'est monsieur
drouard qui m'a inquiété parce que je
suis spécialisé sur le jeu voilà c'est
si vous chercher mon nom j'étais pas sur
la liste
merci beaucoup mais le moulin on est
très contents de vous avoir parmi nous
je vais laisser la parole à la question
portant sur le mode multijoueur alors
c'était une réflexion que nous avions eu
effectivement mais on a décidé de ne pas
la conserver tout simplement en termes
de données personnelles parce que si on
fait un jeu collectif à distance il peut
y avoir ce ce que ce soit à l'oral ou
sous forme de chat
il peut y avoir des déviances qui sont
faites quand je parle de déviance ça
peut être soit une récolte illicites
bien sûr mais ça peut être aussi même en
entre joueurs pardon
voilà il dit de ne pas respecter les
règles tacites politesse ou ce genre de
choses
donc là le jeu en l'occurrence se joue
de manière individuelle mais c'est vrai
que cette réflexion nous l'avions eu
parce qu'on s'était dit ben voilà pour
discuter avec quelqu'un c'est toujours
le sait ce qu'il ya de mieux
effectivement pour reprendre une langue
c'est cette oralité
la deuxième réflexion c'était aussi ils
sont du niveau à 1.1 fin les joueurs on
vise à faire en sorte qu'ils atteignent
ce niveau là donc même si on sait on se
disait un moment voilà ça va être un
francophone qui parle avec un
germanophone comme ça ils vont
progresser c'est un très beau feu
c'est un voeu pieux parce qu'ils n'ont
pas encore le niveau requis pour pouvoir
vraiment communiquer avec quelqu'un
d'autre donc pourquoi pas dans une v3 où
on viserait des niveaux supérieurs en
langue de faire ce système là mais
attention encore une fois aux données
personnelles et à au contrôle voilà on
avait réfléchi à m peut-être un
modérateur aussi pour pour contrôler ce
qui serait dit entre les joueurs ce
genre de choses donc pour l'instant non
mais pourquoi pas mais ce sera un autre
projet c'est ce que c'est vraiment tout
un pan le multijoueur c'est tout un pan
différent de l'application telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui donc il ya une vraie
réflexion on a déjà réfléchi dessus mais
il faut avoir une vraie réflexion pour
l'intégrer par la suite merci ça précise
donc je vais en encore une dernière
question que d'une personne malade
vignes et ou de souligner elle est
exactement la cible les collégiens les
lycéens vidéo évoque les 12 16 ans à la
ronde et sur un public plutôt du niveau
secondaire 1
donc c'est à dire du collège et qu'un
vocation à s'articuler avec le début du
secondaire 2 c'est à dire c'est pour
justement aussi intégrer ces jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi où ces jeunes qui
sont accompagnés par la mission locale
merci beaucoup pour cette question là
toute la question madame ballard
d'applications pourra-t-elle serre et à
mettre en lien des classes dans leurs
supérieurs
je vais faire une réponse rapide les
elle mettra individuellement en relation
les participants avec les entreprises du
rhin supérieur pour puisque alizés à
l'issue de ce jeu une journée découverte
également rencontrer leurs homologues
dire en tout cas leurs collègues
allemands et suisses sur les salons pour
l'emploi en espérant ambitieux faire le
beau possible
en ce virus sera un cul ouais je
remercie madame dhalla et maintenant le
moment le très attendu
le jeune trépigne d'impatience de le
laisser la parole aux enseignants d'état
sein des établissements que j'ai cités
jardins verbal du collège pas aux airs
d'une permutation pour adresser leurs
questions au panel aux officiels
directement encore une fois et je les
remercie parce qu'elles ont participé
une enquête initiale sur les pratiques
numériques a déjà à fin 2010 9
ils ont par la suite tester l'outil lors
de plusieurs phases intermédiaires à
leurs observations leurs suggestions
leurs critiques
on était vraiment très précieuse et ont
permis au groupe de projet d'adapter le
concept ludo pédagogique à ce public
spécifique
merci à elle merci à eux et maintenant
nous leur donnons la parole aux cadets
précisant le calendrier pour la mise en
oeuvre de l'application donc
l'application comme vous l'avez compris
et téléchargeable de la version donc de
la langue cadres français vers la langue
site allemand des guerres et
l'application donc la seconde
application qui permet à la
réversibilité totale à derry sera
disponible de l'allemande blanche cadre
et le français comme langue sim a quant
à elle disponible début février ont le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre de
l'application et au niveau du projet du
coup est prévu que ces isotopes badge
sais c'est attestation de réussite au
jeu puisse être délivrés aux jeunes des
délais maintenant recouvert droit à ces
journées découvertes transfrontalières
en entreprise en milieu professionnel
pour en février dans la limite et en
tenant compte des contraintes sanitaires
on espère le plus tôt possible
voilà pour le calendrier de mise en
oeuvre du projet intérêts et
l'articulation de telus dans les
établissements scolaires donc
l'articulation qui est prévu c'est une
utilisation comme l'a évoqué monsieur
grade en temps scolaire et hors du temps
scolaire avec la possibilité d'une
autorisation d'une dérogation dans le
cadre des outils numériques utilisés
dans un cadre pédagogique un don qu'il y
avait possibilité
station en temps scolaire qui doublera
une utilisation individuelle hors temps
scolaire mais qui pourra être guidé
accompagnés par les enseignants qui
pourrait dire aux jeunes de télécharger
l'outil est d'atteindre tel ou tel
niveau pour se donner des objectifs a
donc ignoré voilà il y aurait une
symbiose entre le les enseignants et les
utilisateurs sur ce dans ce cadre pour
répondre à votre question et c'est pour
ça qu'il était très important d'avoir du
coup la participation des autorités
scolaires françaises suisses et
allemandes comme l'ont rappelé monsieur
frisait connaît madame meubles et madame
la rectrice la porte pour voilà ces
retours d'expérience dans les deux sens
aussi du côté des enseignants et du
potet deux des équipes et des experts
pédagogique est aussi également de
monsieur schneider et des humide et
autres partenaires voilà voilà pour
cette question
alors je vais en reprendre des questions
du collège charles walch de thann
ils nous ont été adressées par les
filles envisage-t-on d'élargir à
l'avenir cette application à la france
entière ainsi qu'à l'allemagne ou
territoires allemands étaient autant de
la suisse 1 dans la mesure où cette
application est gratuite les accessible
partout en france à l'étranger enfin
voilà il me semble surtout sur tous les
continents
donc pas de soucis effectivement pour
généraliser cette application tout le
monde que la charge est là librement sur
son téléphone sur son départ d'un sur
tous les supports
vous avez en même temps répondu à une
question qui nous a été posée sur
facebook
nous remercions du coup les spectateurs
et les spectatrices indus facebook live
we l'application est gratuite elle peut
être utilisée dans toute la france une
autre question qui nous a été posée aux
et par les élèves du collège charles
debbasch
quels sont les prochains tests ou les
prochaines vérification que doit passer
d'application avant la mise sur le
marché
est-ce que antoine tu pourrais monde à
cette question alors maintenant pour la
v2 effectivement qui qui va faire en
sorte que le joueur apprennent la langue
allemande
on va pouvoir effectivement de tester le
jeu bas auprès d'un panel donc toutes
les classes qui sont volontaires ou tous
les volontaires pourront tester le jeu
pour vérifier c'est toujours pareil dans
une application si le jeu fonctionne
bien qu'il n'y a pas de bug et s'éteint
et c'est donc là maintenant j'ai envie
de dire tout ce qui est univers et style
visuel on le concert de toute façon s'il
ya eu plusieurs tests là dessus et le
développement a déjà été fait de ce côté
là en revanche pour tester le jeu
la v2 on peut on peut le distribuer de
la même manière qu'on est de nous avions
distribué la v1 on peut distribuer à
tous les volontaires question madame si
le collège de nerval de ville des mises
à jour lui tout à fait tout à fait c'est
c'est un peu comme vous les voyez devant
les applications que vous pouvez
télécharger enfin toutes les autres
applications vous télécharger sur votre
smartphone elle se met à jour
régulièrement donc c'est soit pour
corriger des bugs ce soit pour améliorer
des petites fonctionnalités
donc nous on nous pouvons mettre à jour
l'application donc si vous repérez
quelque chose ou s'il est décidé de
changer quelque chose on pourra mettre
l'application à jour surtout comme je le
répète encore une fois nous avons levé 2
qui sortira en février 2021 sur laquelle
nous allons commencer à travailler dès
maintenant
donc toutes les choses j'ai envie de
dire toutes les petites optimisations
que nous pourrons faire sur les
fonctionnalités nous pourrons le faire
aussi pour la v1 et mettront à jour la
v1 de manière à ce que les deux
applications enfin je parle de deux
applications mais c'est la même mais
réversibles soit identique vraiment en
termes de fonctionnalités et
d'optimisation mais on peut faire comme
je le dis des mises à jour tout au long
du du projet
alors antoine une question de la classe
de man and broad également en collège
charles walch de thann
mais vous mettre davantage de
personnages ou permet de choisir de
nouvelles tenues
alors pour des nouveaux personnages donc
je suppose et nouvelle célébrité c'est
faisable mais là encore une fois c'est
ce serait j'ai envie de dire un autre
projet qui commencerait parce que on est
sur une application qui serait plus
lourde c'est en fait c'est pour ça tout
à l'heure quand je disais qu'il ya eu un
vote démocratique on ne peut pas mettre
tous les personnages qu'on veut parce
que l'application pèsera plus lourd plus
son maître visuel puis son maître sont
plus l'application est lourde mais c'est
faisable bien entendu et pour les tenues
des joueurs c'est faisable également
mais encore une fois il faudra que qq
que nous touchons à certaines choses
mais ce dans l'absolu c'est ça serait
faisable
alors j'ai une dernière question d'un
élève du collège charles debbasch donc
la classe de madame route
combien de temps avez vous mis pour
créer ce jeu alors c'est une question
qui s'adresse à plusieurs participants
autour de ce zoom de la ligue 1 je les
ai faits d'abord la parole à madame
julie hier puis aussi antoine gras
laïcité l'air aux autres artères qui
sera très dire un mot sur les coulisses
de la conception de ce projet la parole
est à vous à juillet alors c'est vrai
que c'est une idée qui a été lancée je
crois il ya deux ans en fait c'est ça
semble longuement tout baisser c'est
très rapide aussi nous avions exprimé
nous les élus avec notre présidente
vous n'allez pas que j'ai deux compères
teint le souhait de mettre à disposition
des jeunes un outil leur permettant
effectivement d'approcher la langue de
façon ludique pour l'apprentissage des
démos qui nous permette effectivement
d'aller à la rencontre est de pouvoir
communiquer en langue allemande avec nos
voisins suisses et allemands
et cette idée a fait son chemin et voilà
donc nous nous sommes rapprochés
effectivement d'un certain nombre des
parts des partenaires vous avez évoqué
mais aussi de notre fournisseur
voilà qui nous a proposé effectivement
un scénario et voilà d'une idée
effectivement d'une offre
d'apprentissage ludique et pratique à
bas aujourd'hui deux ans après nous
sommes effectivement à vous proposer
cette application complète et évolutive
un grand merci roumanoff univers
messieurs schneider auteur je vous
souhaitez ajouter quelque chose sur la
genèse du projet messieurs frisé que ou
très volontiers si oui certainement pour
pour dire à quel point je dirais la
démarche créative de l'application a été
un temps d'innovation notamment dans
lequel je vais dire l'ensemble des
partenaires et aussi mes collègues de
réseaux canopée que j'en profite pour
remercier ont pu une certaine manière
coopérer autour de cet objet mettre en
place de l'ingénierie de projet de
l'ingénierie éditoriale et prendre en
compte les besoins pédagogiques et je
crois que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui a fonctionné qui a été un temps
collaboratif très créatif et c'est vrai
que cette cette démarche cette
méthodologie a permis aussi d'avancer
vers la construction de l'objet qui ne
connaissons que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
et puis juste un petit mot aussi pour un
aspect qui a été évoquée à travers les
questions qui est celui de la diffusion
aujourd'hui de cet objet qui me semble à
un point extrêmement important
cette diffusion évidemment elle doit
aujourd'hui faire l'objet d'une
communication mais aussi elle doit être
portée par les acteurs et je rappelle
que nous nous serons également présents
nos médiateurs sont présents à l'échelle
de nos ateliers auprès des collègues des
écoles des collèges et des lycées
également pourrait bien apporter
l'information et puis participer au
développement des usages et enfin un
dernier mot qui me semble extrêmement
important aussi ça a été soulignée par
notre partenaire média je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui est essentiel
c'est que ce développement repose sur
les usages et et merci encore aux
classes et les élèves parce que c'est
grâce à eux aussi que cet objet a pu
voir le jour et que le bleu le contour
je dirais de l'objet tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui a pu être dessinée donc je
crois que vraiment le ce projet est
original innovant par sa dimension
collaboratif mais aussi parce qu'il
repose sur les parcours utilisateur et
sur les l'analyse des usagers sur
l'expression des besoins par les élèves
et les
les enseignants donc ça me paraît
vraiment une démarche très innovante a
souligné un grand merci à vous monsieur
schneider de mettre en lumière cette ce
volet très important du projet aussi à
la diffusion et l'amplification de la
diffusion de l'application je vois le
monsieur euro de terre de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie souhaité
s'exprimer si vous le souhaitez vous
avez la parole sur nos terres mais très
rapidement pour pour dire que
l'apprentissage des langues
enfin plutôt les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
sont les salariés demain je suis
toujours un peu mono monoproduit c'est à
dire je défends des entreprises et que
un bon niveau de langue notamment
allemands de notre région peut être
également un élément de différenciation
lors de recrutements de guti vraiment
tous les jeunes qui nous écoutent à a
commencé très tôt à apprendre la langue
on craque pour ça merci beaucoup à vous
messieurs interne et souvenez cette
dimension enfin pour rappel le projet
s'inscrit dans l'objectif thématique 8
du programme interreg iv du coup à
favoriser l'emploi au sein du passage de
litres et national du rhin supérieur
merci beaucoup un dernier élément de la
communication est aussi la diffusion de
l'outil nous vous annonçons projet que
des affiches vont être placés dans les
établissements scolaires alsacien
établissements partenaires allemands
sous peu les affiches du cours reprenant
les visuels que vous pouvez déjà en
avant première sur les réseaux sociaux
du département du haut rhin
et qui seront qui sont déjà munis d'un
qr codes donc un code qr en colombie 6
qui permettra le téléchargement de ces
de cette application gratuite
pour rappel accessible à tous et qui a
fait l'objet d'une aussi beaucoup de
précautions en termes d'utilisation des
données personnelles est vraiment
conforme au cahier des charges en
matière de respectable et soit dit en
passant
s'il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'intervention je n'en vois pas pour
l'instant je propose de passer la parole
à la guerre un mot de clôture
en tant que représentante a vu porteurs
du projet rappelle match d'hier et maire
de saint louis concert départemental et
rapporteur de la roselle commission
action les relations transfrontalières
international membre du conseil
départemental du haut rhin
j'aimerais tout d'abord remercié
l'ensemble des participants et vous avez
été une cinquantaine d' un bel événement
qui a rassemblé beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes des jeunes et voilà les
équipes enseignantes tous les
partenaires financiers institutionnels
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est un moment
qui était très attendue parce qu'on en
parle quand même depuis depuis longtemps
on se rend compte effectivement que
cette application basse est le fruit
d'une collaboration fructueuse entre
beaucoup beaucoup de partenaires et
merci monsieur schneider d'avoir rappelé
effectivement l'implication forte des
uns et des autres mais aussi c'est vrai
que le volet éducatif est très important
1 dans cette application et il a fallu
effectivement entendre les uns les
autres pour arriver aujourd'hui à une
version qu'ils soient qui répondent aux
attentes et aux besoins effectivement
des uns des autres
voilà donc une démarche participative et
collectives tout à fait innovante est
intéressante
et on peut considérer effectivement que
que le rendu aujourd'hui le fruit
effectivement de la qualité de ce
partenariat est de l'implication
effectivement fructueuse des uns et des
autres alors pour pour de volée alors
nous l'avons rappelé à plusieurs
reprises
l'apprentissage de la langue bien sûr
c'est compris aujourd'hui comme un
levier d'insertion professionnelle et
cet outil est tout à fait adapté en
effectivement pour l'apprentissage de
mots de formules qui permettront aux
jeunes effectivement de pouvoir
approcher avoir des premiers contacts
avec un futur employeur
que ce soit en suisse en allemagne mais
aussi en france en alsace puisque nos
entreprises c'est effectivement ont
besoin de cette compétence linguistique
dans l'eure dans leurs activités
et puis aussi on peut considérer que cet
outil aussi je parlais de lever
d'insertion professionnelle mais aussi
on peut parler de levier d'insertion
culturel multiculturelle parce que à
travers effectivement avec kraft à bas
les jeunes peuvent découvrir la richesse
de notre patrimoine culturel de nos
sites touristiques mais aussi des
personnages historiques qui font
l'histoire est effectivement de nos
territoires transfrontaliers
merci à vous tous pour votre
collaboration et votre participation
active et notamment aux collégiens aux
jeunes merci un grand mât serbe hommage
une guerre merci de vos contributions à
toutes et à tous au sein de ce webinaire
votre intérêt pour le projet et intérêts
or du rhin dont l'application avait raté
lui des actions principales soit
vraiment très heureux parce agents
nombreuses aujourd'hui
pour rappel le jeu étant gratuit chacune
et chacun peut le télécharger
c'est bientôt noël enchères vos
petits-enfants à leurs enfants à l'onia
ça me veut avant tout ça c'est kobe de
compatible vous pouvez le télécharger
sur google paye sur l'app store en
saisissant simplement le mot avec caf
écrit avec un cas il s'agit comme l'a
rappelé match rien d'une combinaison
d'un mot français d'un mot allemand et a
dû tout d'un mot anglais laissez vous
prendre au jeu le jeu c'est l' aventure
c'est avec kraft c'est vous c'est nous
et pour rappel la vidéo du webinaire
sera archivée sur le compte facebook du
département du haut rhin
merci encore et a passé une folle
journée par ici